ob die ganze geschichte fake oder echt
ist darüber möchte ich heute mit euch in
diesem video reden für die die sich
jetzt fragen ob er über lammert der typ
eigentlich leo matschie hat gestern ein
video hochgeladen in dem er mit abu raed
ins kino ein gebrochenes die beiden
jungs nicht nur ins kino eingebrochen
sondern sind dann da auch 24 stunden
geblieben
dieses videos einfach so witzig auf so
vielen verschiedenen ebenen das ist
comedy
das ist wirklich comedy dass es kein
projekt die haben einfach unfreiwillig
da wirklich comedy gemacht zum beispiel
der titel lautet irgendwie so 24 stunden
neben kino eingesperrt ja 24 stunden auf
jeden fall stunden ist ein ganzer tag
die gehen aber im dunkeln rein und noch
im dunkeln wieder raus wenn man jetzt
mal einen dass die sonne um 16.30
untergeht so um den dreh ist es gerade
und um 6 wieder aufgeht bleiben
13 einhalb stunden das heißt selbst wenn
sie von dem zeitpunkt wo die sonne
untergegangen ist wo es gerade dunkel
wurde bis zum zeitpunkt wo die sonne
wieder aufregung ist groß gerade hell
wurde also quasi die maximale zeit vor
einem kino gewesen sind dass sie gar
nicht waren waren es nur 13 stunden und
keine 24 stunden aber ganz ehrlich leute
wir sollten nicht zu viel von jungs
erwarten deswegen machen wir es erstmal
weiter
falls euch jetzt fragt okay wie machen
wir das in dem video wie prüfen wir
zusammen auf das video echt oder fake
ist ich habe mir das video mehrmals
angeschaut ich werde jetzt keine
ausschnitte in diesem video zeigen von
deren video einfach aus dem grund dass
mich da nicht reichen können ich weiß ja
nicht was bei den ab geht bei den sind
13 stunden 24 stunden leben
offensichtlich in einer anderen zeitzone
in der die zeit schneller vergeht als
bei uns also leute vorsicht eines der
ersten highlights in dem über die gabe
müssen den leuten jahr will zeigen wie
wir uns fühlen und wir haben jetzt real
werden ist keine motivation das in so
einem video von der person die
garantiert schon großteil der fans
gezeigt hat hat so es hat ein bisschen
beigeschmack wenn die person die auf
youtube um nicht gewählt oder
korrekteste ist sowas erzählt dann
geht's weiter blablabla das video dauert
erstmal ewig bist du wirklich im kino
sind dann sind sie im kinosaal und sie
verstecken sich im notausgang als wenn
wir uns den kinosaal so vorstellen hier
die sitze da die leinwand dann haben sie
sich hier in so einem notausgang der
anti vor dem vorhang war was rein
theoretisch hätte funktionieren können
aber dann sitzen sie dann diesen
notausgang und labert einfach ich weiß
nicht was mitteln ab gegen die
wahrscheinlich einfach langweilig die
wurst nicht was sie sagen sollen aber
anfangen auf einmal ein geschichten zu
erzählen so ortega 250.000 likes wer
schon geil
zitat ab red das ist kein normales video
das ist premium das ist kein normales
video das ist premium also ich bin mir
nicht ganz sicher leute ob entweder
seine zuschauer zu bemühungen prank
zufrieden oder tatsächlich
hausfriedensbruch was straftat zu
begehen premium ist aber die fallen
könnte ich vielleicht selbst beantworten
dann geht es weiter in seinem bodyguard
wenn das video kraft es endlich gefallen
dann lasst mal 88.000 likes auf
instagram da ich weiß nicht irgendwas
daran mag ich nicht so dieses wort
250.000 leistung dieses video 88.000
likes of instagram mindestens 3000
fanbriefe bis zur nächsten woche an mich
oder ich mache kein video
ich finde einfach ich finds komisch
während sie sich in diesem versteck
aufhalten hört man auch um die stimmen
von außen und leute ihm vorbeilaufen
wobei das theoretisch theoretisch wenn
es abgesprochen ist und gefragt ist auch
deren kollegen seien könnten die am
anfang mit ihnen unterwegs warnt aber
dann verzieht sich die angeblichen
mitarbeiter des kinos und die kommen aus
diesem notausgang raus und dann sagen
sie eine sache die ich sehr
bemerkenswert finde und zwar und zwar
sagt leon
red da sind noch unsere getränke von
vorhin da das würde bedeuten dass nicht
aufgeräumt wurde in diesem kino saal
weil deren getränke stehen ganz mal den
platz halten und die hatten ihre
getränke nicht mit in ihrem versteck
sondern die waren an ihren sitzen und
das würde bedeuten dass nicht aufgeräumt
wurde was wiederum bedeuten würde dass
das kino personal nicht in dem sarah war
danach aufgeräumter beim kind nach jeder
vorstellung aufgeräumt wird ihr wisst
wie es im kino ist man selbst schmeißt
an den popcorn rum und lässt überall so
kann man das geht natürlich nicht
hinterlassen das heißt deswegen gedacht
jeder vorstellung da jemand durch aber
wenn die flaschen so viel später noch da
standen wenn die flasche noch darstellt
nach den angeblich mitarbeiter drin
waren
ist das für mich ein indiz dass es keine
mitarbeiter waren die man da gehört hat
und das ist eventuell ein fake ist was
ich auch noch sehr ersetzt findet ab
von den leuten am einlass und ich glaube
einer frau eine lebensmittel theke und
das ist bevor sie noch mal rausgehen
oder wieder reinkommen sieht man
überhaupt keine mitarbeiter oder
kinogäste in diesem video und das finde
ich schon ist sales eigentlich hätte man
auch der kinogäste sehen müssen sie
haben ihr gesagt sie sehen sich eine
vorstellung kino an dem er gesagt habe
ich einen film angeschaut dafür müssten
vorbei eigentlich hätten dadurch leute
drin sein muss ihre normale youtuber
hätte wahrscheinlich gefilmt wie er ins
kino rein geht in den kinosaal und dann
halt ein paar leute auf der aufnahme
drauf ich schon im kinosaal drin sitzen
auch bei denen ist einfach keine andere
kino gast zu sehen im ganzen ganzen
video kriegen leon und marschieren
upgrade eine privatveranstaltung im kino
ich glaub nicht da müsste eigentlich
auch anders sein aber die sieht man
nicht was für mich dafür spricht dass
sie sich mit irgendeinem typen vom kino
abgesprochen haben es gab keine
filmvorstellung gab sondern er sie
einfach so rein gelassen hat und zwar
nach ladenschluss und das wird natürlich
bedeuten dass das ding fake ist noch
eine komische sache ist sie tun so als
prinzip enso 1 2 stunden in den kinosaal
gehen dann rauskommt leonor mit nacho
sun mitten in der nacht gibt es auch im
kino keinen schuss mehr die rollen doch
alles leer ich kann beim besten willen
nicht vorstellen dass die iren adsche
reserven über nacht einfach offen
herumstehen lassen niemals niemals die
werden doch nicht besser mit der zeit
ich glaube die machen nachts einfach
alles zu machen die pop von maschinen
leer machen die nachos lehrer dann
geht's weiter laufen sie darum in den
öffentlichen kino gang da wo auch die
essens und dann behauptet einer von den
beiden dass er die polen gesehen hätte
und da gibt's zur diskussion hier wohl
wurden hier nachhinein ein quatsch
praktisch doch doch doch das rennen das
rennen denn rennens wieder weg aber
nicht an dieser stelle und auch nicht am
ende des videos sind überhaupt
polizisten im video zu sehen man sieht
einfach keine polizisten die bio dennoch
reden sie die ganze darüber dass die
polizei angeblich da ist dann hätte man
die auch theoretisch filmen können am
ende kommen die beiden jungs dann auch
wieder aus dem kino raus wobei sie einen
alarm auslösen und das ist einer der
kritischsten punkte auf der positiven
seite also der seite die dafür spricht
dass das video echt ist in meinen augen
denn sollen alarm nachzustellen stelle
ich mir echt schwierig vor also quasi
nachzustellen die zitronen vom alarm
verändert wenn man die tür zumacht da wo
sie ausgegangen sind oder dann auf der
straße ist ja auch ein alarm
das ist glaube ich so weit ich mich mit
schnittprogrammen auskennen audio
bearbeitungsprogramm auskenne relativ
tricky und das würde mich natürlich ganz
stark dafür sprechen dass das video echt
ist es ist echt schwierig zu sagen also
das urteil ist nicht leicht ist es bei
dem video nicht so dass man
hundertprozentig sagen könnte dass es
fake oder 100 ehrlich sagen finde es
echt ist es ist richtig zu schätzen die
beiden und weggerannt sind also aus dem
kino raus und irgendwo anders hin sitzen
sie dann im auto und dann kommt wieder
so eine stelle wo ich mir denke so hey
es wird mega gestellt und zwar seit red
da wir müssen die aufnahme abbrechen die
polizei wir müssen die aufnahme
abbrechen so richtig schlecht
geschauspielert also wirklich richtig
schlechte schauspieler muss ich denke
das ist doch nicht authentisch das merkt
auch jeder ist es nicht echt ist und
dieses wirklich wirklich schlecht
gestartet wir müssen die aufnahme
abbrechen am ende wird auch wieder fake
und deshalb dem eindruck bei dass das
video fähig ist also was man
abschließend dazu sagen ich würde den
beiden auf jeden fall zutrauen dumm
genug zu sein wirklich der
einzuberechnen die straftat zu begehen
weil ich meine dass laden die auf
youtube hoch dass ihnen eine million
leute das feld garantiert auf die zurück
wenn sich wirklich gemacht haben
andererseits haben wir aber auch viele
hinweise dafür dass das ding eventuell
fake sein könnte wie zum beispiel die
tatsache dass die getränke nicht
weggeräumt wurden keine anderen leute zu
sehen sind keine polizisten zu sehen
sind und am ende so richtig schlecht
geschauspielert gesagt wurde der wir
müssen die aufnahme letzten endes stehen
red und lehrer maschinen beiden fällt
schlechter weil sie entweder weil sie
entweder blöd genug waren eine straftat
zu begehen und das finden
millionenpublikum hochzuladen oder weil
sie einfach so dreist waren und das wird
ein kinobesitzer abgesprochen haben und
das dann als echten prank verkaufen und
so ihre zuschauer blieben so oder so ich
bin bei dem video kommen die jungs nicht
wirklich gut weg mit 150000 leute leid
die dieses video gezeigt haben dass
deutschlands zukunft 150000 likes auf
einem video in dem man aus gruppe geht
so dass wohl heute dass man meine
argumente statt gerne mal eure meinung
zu den ganzen dingen die kommentare und
bis zum nächsten